[Music]
joe rogan like when i was watching that
clip of joe rogan on instagram being
like hey uh did you watch that no i need
to get caught up because there was a
whole bunch of i mean if you don't know
you've probably seen this already if you
don't know neil young
took his music off spotify because uh
joe rogan is like spreading
misinformation about vaccines or
whatever i guess joe rogan has had like
these anti-vaccine people on
uh recently and like all in a row too
yeah just kind of like dude okay yeah
like have some people from the other
side on yeah sure so people are really
mad and neil young's one of them so he
took his music on spotify and their
market cap dropped by like four billion
dollars all because of neil young how
how does he have that much market share
though four billion dollars he's worth
four times kim kardashian no he's not
the market like people sold the stock so
much that their market cap was it erased
four billion dollars off their valuation
as a company
but like even that i'm like i guess they
people thought it's indicative of like a
greater trend of maybe
people not liking joe rogan and
boycotting spotify
so i mean it bounced back but um
so that happened and then basically joe
rogan went on instagram and it was did
this nine minute video basically saying
hey uh i am sorry about you know having
so many people on from one side of an
argument i have to work on having other
people on and i totally support spotify
and putting up a preemptive warning on
whatever content has to do with vaccines
and the whole time i'm watching this and
he's like i never thought the podcast
would grow to be what it is today and
the whole time i was watching i was like
i can't
either i like i can't believe that
you're the arbiter now of like
truth truth and pop cult he's right in
the [ __ ] middle everybody talks about
him and if you go through the comments
of his of that post it's nuts
it's the amount of blue checks it's like
four million blue checks being like
you're the [ __ ] man joe yeah
i love you dude i waited i took a glance
and at the time i had posted it had only
been up for a couple hours and the
comments were already 15 000. yeah i was
like this dude 10 years ago was getting
people to eat spiders on tv well that
should have been a sign that he was
gonna get people to do anything yeah
it's crazy that people actually logged
into instagram to comment on this you
know what i mean rock on rogan and the
rock commented on it was like dude i saw
that uh can't wait to come on brother
and bust out the tequila dude
couldn't you just texted him what's
hilarious is
this this is like when six nine was
popping yeah look at this every blue
check is just on here you know doing
their marketing you know they're
networking they're all just yeah joe
you're my guy too joe yeah we're friends
too joe joe text me later i know it's
crazy right now but you didn't know bro
hit me offline dude because we have each
other's numbers we do indeed yeah keep
going what's a funny one this is
honestly like instead of being well
[ __ ] athlean x
who's that who is that
who is that
[ __ ] jeff cavalier you've seen this
guy on youtube jeff cavaliereth.com
i'm going to teach you 10 ways that your
biceps are being torn because you don't
know how to work out
step one the standard bicep curl
horrible for you what's up guys i mean
obviously this guy likes joe rogan
though yeah i think yeah i think the
hate machine is so big that like instead
of being
drake or michael jackson
or the weeknd this is how you get famous
now you have to be so [ __ ] polarizing
because it's all like algorithm driven
and the more people you can have arguing
on your [ __ ] the more twitter will put
you on their discover page and people
will make content about you it's like
that's how you get spread around i know
it's kind of crazy i [ __ ] hate it
it's whack anyways fear factor we got
some oh let's watch an old clip
[Applause]
all right here we go with number 12 on
our most outrageous moments list
yo stop it this man was made for fame i
know seriously in that [ __ ] triple xl
button-up shirt
in front of a panda express at universal
studios
he's got this crowd going crazy who's
ready to see someone eat a spider
[Applause]
nuts man
he's got it he's got the it
all right
well as you know animals can be wild
unpredictable and dangerous
oh yeah we know that we use hungry
alligators
no way joe
that's why we've taken 14 squids and
we're gonna run them over with some cars
giant squids from the depths of the
bermuda they're each going to go for a
swim in this tank here
seems pretty easy right
well not if i toss it like pause it
pause it
you think if someone went up to him and
was like hey dude you know in 15 years
there's gonna be a global pandemic and
you're gonna be right in the middle of
like the argument about the vaccine that
was
rushed out to save humanity it's gonna
be you
he'd be like
ah maybe
yeah
yeah what a what a what a progression
this dude has had yeah and i think this
just speaks to why a career in
entertainment is so dangerous look what
it does to your brain i think even young
joe like if he was shown a visual of
himself he'd be like wait wait so my
nipples get harder [ __ ] and then i get
in that
bathtub
and then i put that on the internet and
i just breathe for 10 minutes and i get
on testosterone replacement therapy
dude this is kind of grim damn it how
much do i make though yeah yeah yeah
there you go
wait stop
stop baby little gators no did you see
that shot of that gator swimming that
for sure looked like a 10 year old in a
ninja turtle suit yeah that didn't even
look like a [ __ ] alligator look at
this let it run again
it looks like a kid in there
all right just like float around
hold your breath yeah
those are alligators ladies
real live alligators do you know
something how condescending dude i'm
sorry yeah yeah seriously way to
mansplain that ladies those are what's
known as alligators
you're not allowed to read books and let
me tell you the way yeah
we just busted into one of his joe rogan
rants right there you know what's funny
about alligators the way they reproduce
is they actually
just dude shut up man joe not now yeah
not now you're supposed to be scaring
them alligators are crazy they'll rip
your [ __ ] head off
bite off your ass
remember that cleveland yeah
[Laughter]
like with some part of that he says like
a monkey [ __ ] your ass they would rip
your [ __ ] feet off
and [ __ ] your ass
i think so i don't know why [ __ ] your
asses
[Laughter]
head to the bottom and retrieve the
poles one at a time and place them on a
rack
[Music]
you're really gonna do this nicole
[Music]
well she just gets like
[ __ ] mutilated yeah i was gonna say
here's a
tank of piranhas
honestly i wouldn't put it past
television from this era i don't i just
did a video about the show called the
chamber it's like it's just a torture
chamber and contestants go inside and
they just torture them as they answer
questions oh dude i mean film in like
the 50s and the 20s was literally like
let's kill all the extras there's like
some biblical movie where there's like a
scene where there's drowning and they
fill like a studio room with water and
people drown to death it's like five
people died wow the director was
probably like
say print it yeah do you have more yeah
more extras right they didn't all die
yeah okay let's make that happen
you